You have to walk before you can run, crawl
before you can walk, and make it through a
pelvis before you can crawl.
Hello bipeds, Julian in for DNews.
Compared to other animals, humans have a lot
going for us.
We’re intelligent, we’re long lived, we
have the internet.
But in some areas we get left in the dust.
Take walking for instance.
While newborn horses are standing up and walking
within hours of their birth, dumb ol’ babies
take a year to start waddling around.
Why are humans so good at complex things,
but so terrible at the simple stuff like walking?
It turns out two of our defining human characteristics,
our brain size and our upright walking, are
at odds with each other.
The hypothesis is, when our ancestors came
down from the trees and started walking across
the savannah 3 to 6 million years ago, a more
upright posture was an advantage.
It used less energy than knuckling on all
fours, allowing our extremely great grandparents
to cover large distances more easily.
To support this upright stance our hips had
to change shape, and with this change in shape
came a narrowing of the birth canal.
According to Cal State Fullerton anthropologist
John Bock, this is where our delayed ambulatory
skills come from.
Your brain has to be developed enough to control
all your limbs before you can start walking.
But this brain development makes your head
bigger, and if your head is bigger, you can’t
get through the birth canal, and if you can’t
get through the birth canal you don’t get
born.
Not so smart with your big brain now, are
you, stuck genius baby?
To work around the dilemma, babies are born
with comparatively underdeveloped brains.
They also need soft skulls so they can squish
their way out of momma.
The bones in our skulls aren’t fused together
at birth, leaving room for our brains to double
in size in our early years.8 So for us to
become smarter, we had to start out dumber
and vulnerable.
There’s an inspiring instagram post in there
somewhere.
Once you take into account that we’re born
with less developed brains than our animal
friends, the reason for our time spent as
rugrats makes a little more sense.
In 2009 Martin Garwicz of Lund University
in Sweden authored a study comparing how long
various mammals took to start walking.
He and his team compared 24 species, looking
at what their brain size was when they took
their first steps relative to their final
adult brain size.
Garwicz formed a timeline predicting when
a species would get off the ground, and crucially
the timeline starts at conception, not birth.
With conception as the starting point, humans
began walking when they hit the same developmental
milestone as other animals.
For example, horses are walking in just a
few hours, but that’s because they spend
up to a year in the womb and their brains
are almost fully developed at birth.
Garwicz also explored whether our bipedalism
delays us compared to our quadruped pals,
and found that it does have a small effect:
the added complexity of heel-to-toe walking
makes us hit our stride a little later.
That characteristic, along with our less developed
brains at birth, means we take baby steps
towards taking baby steps.
So now you know why humans walk later than
other animals, but how about some other fun
animal facts?
Check out our friends over at Did You Know
for more...
So we can walk upright eventually like everyone
else, except snakes, sorry snakes.
But we can never walk up walls like spiders.
To learn why you can never be spider man and
ruin your whole day, check out Trace’s video
here.
This
video was inspired by a viewer question on
facebook, thanks Jorge.
If you’d like to ask a question there are
tons of ways to ask us.